Ibraham, your books, uh, Sword and
Scimitar, I tell everybody, you got to
get all three. Sword and Scitar, which
tells the whole story of the great war
against of the Christian West, uh, the
our Judeo-Christian civilization
against, uh, Islam, defenders of the
West, you take the individual stories,
and this is one I give to young men all
the time, um, and women and young women.
Uh, your new your new one, the two
swords of Christ, about the military
orders from the Crusades. But I want to
ask you a contemporary problem. You're
in Budapest right now. You're a fellow
over in the institute of a country that
got it right. Hungary got it right.
Poland got it right. As you look on this
situation in the streets because now
it's up in the open. The Red Green
Alliance. People say, "Oh no, that's a
crazy conspiracy theory because the
Islamist uh and the Sharia law guys
totally hate the Marxists, etc. Is the
Red Green Alliance li alive, sir, in
Europe and the United States?"
>> Absolutely. without, excuse me, without
the red green alliance, especially the
red portion, the green wouldn't even be
a problem. In other words, if you look
specifically at Europe, let's say, why
why islam a problem? Is it because
they've come at the way they used to in
the seventh, eth, and nth centuries on
with swords and horseback and there's
nothing that Europeans can do? No.
They're there because the Red Alliance
that they work for, which is also also
known as Europe's leadership, is
bringing them in by the boat loads and
um and doing everything to help them,
including by suppressing their own
citizens, the people who actually voted
them into power and putting them up in
hotels and whatever the case may be, not
allowing any kind of free speech or
criticism of Islam. So absolutely
there's you you can the Islamic threat
to the west today as opposed to
yesterday historically is inconceivable
without the green excuse me without the
red helping the green because this is
not the medieval era where Europe was
the the weak horse which it was actually
especially in the early centuries and
Islam was the behemoth. This is now
where the west is super powerful
financially, economically, economically,
militarily, technologically, every which
way you can imagine compared to by and
large the backwards Islamic world. And
yet these migrants are there in these
countries terrorizing people. And how is
that? Why is that? How could it come to
be? It's entirely because of the red.
You know, you were on War Room Texas the
other day and the reception of that, I
can tell you because the show's on fire,
the the traction on this on the
streaming side. Uh, you really
galvanized a lot of people and had them
wake up when you said this is
civilizational warfare and you have to
understand it as that. And it's much
more sophisticated than blowing up
buildings or the the the the more
standard jihadist moves you saw from a
couple years ago, couple decades ago.
Talk to us. What do you mean by
civilizational warfare? Because you get
you got people's attention when you said
that.
Well, this is uh this these the problem
is too many people have a sort of myopic
view of what's happening and they think
these problems are just started you know
now or a decade ago or two decades ago
and they think they're temporal by
nature in fact they are you know there's
nothing new under the sun as
Ecclesiastes says and exactly everything
we're seeing today in the west the way
Muslims are behaving minus of course the
red enablement that we just discussed
because that didn't really exist uh it
did later on but not in preodern
medieval era because everyone was
collectively fighting against Islam. But
that what we're seeing is just a
complete continuum of what started 14
centuries ago. And so it is in fact a
civilizational conflict. Trump was
absolutely right to call it that in his
uh national strategy document that was
published in by the white house in
November where he said where he said um
Europe is suffering civilizational
eraser. Okay. And that's exactly what's
going on. um minus uh countries like uh
Budapest or the city of Budapest and
Hungary where I'm at right now where
they still have a strong collective
sense of an identity of a Christian
identity and um you know by the way by
by the way a quick a quick interesting
note I think you'd be interested by is
you know how we always hear that white
Christian nationalism fosters
anti-semitism well as it happens a study
came out that in Hungary and especially
in Budapest this is one of the safest
place for Jews and it's also one of the
most Christian and nationalist European
[clears throat]
nations. Okay. Um and on the other hand,
if you look at where the rise of
anti-semitism is in Europe, it's
primarily the main places that have seen
a massive spike are the UK, Germany, and
France. All of which are not connected
or seen in any which way as Christian
nationalist countries, but actually as
liberal secular nations. And we know
what what does one make of that
conundrum? finally realize that the
missing factor between all this is not
that Christian nationalism is bad. Nor
is it necessarily that liberal
secularism is bad. It's that liberal
secularism though opens the door to
something that is bad for Jews, which is
Islam. And so if you look at France and
the UK and Germany, they have the
absolute highest um population of
Muslims in Europe. And at the same time,
the the attacks on on Jews in those
three countries have spiked as have the
attacks on Christians because another
report that was published by the
Observatory of Christianophobia in
Europe found another massive spike of
attacks on Christians in Europe and and
mostly in the UK and in Germany and in
France. And the number one cause that it
cited um that propels these attacks on
Christians was what it calls radical
Islamist ideology. your books. You've
got Sword and Scimitar, which the
overall 1400 warrior head, Defenders of
the West, which are the heroes in that
fight. Your new book. Tell me, give me a
minute or two on your new book about the
two swords of Christ. You can't put it
down. Particular if you're a Christian,
you need this.
Yeah, this is a a close-up panoramic
view of the crusades through seen
through the lives and the eyes of the
most uh the commando forces of the
crusades essentially which were the
knights of the temple and the hospital,
the military orders. And I think people
will be shocked to see what the what the
crusades really were as opposed to how
they're sort of uh um you know uh
caricatured both in movies and in actual
uh supposedly secondary uh histories
that are supposed to be serious. But
these were men who what I found
interesting about them and what I think
readers will find interesting is that on
the one hand they were extremely
committed pious Christians and on the
other hand they weren't what pious
Christians are today which is doormats.
They were actually the exact opposite.
They were ferocious defenders of the
faith. Um, and they found no conflict
between the two and in fact they had
multiple ways to rationalize it directly
through scripture.
>> I want this book not just for yourself
will inspire you but also if you have a
young man in your life get this book for
him. either Defenders of the West, which
is the story of 10 of them from El Sid,
uh, all the way through to even Va V
Vlad the Impaler, which kind of gets he
he's gotten a bad rap in history as
Dracula has a bad rap, which you got to
read the book. And, uh, the the military
orders are fascinating.
The the people, the Knights Hospitaler
from St. John's, St. John's and of
course the Knights Templar is just and
they'll learn a ton of history, but
they'll also be inspired by some uh some
men that were just quite extraordinary
and defended their faith. Like I said,
they weren't doormats. You're in Hungary
and you're you're now been invited,
you're a senior fellow at the Danube
Institute.
Uh and Orban, who obviously we're close
to and think the world of, he stood in
the breach and the Hungarians backed him
up and said, "No, we're not going to
have this happen to our country." And
you see the problems everywhere else
except in Poland and Hungary generally.
Is France in England too far gone? Is
the population is the Islam Islamic
population too high? Because this is
what people in Texas ask all the time.
They're saying, "We see uh the guests
you have on there talking. We see in the
streets, we see the footage what's
happening in England. We see what's
happening in France. We're not going to
have that. Not that we hope it doesn't
happen. We're not going to have that in
Texas." Are those two countries too far
gone? uh or can they sort this problem
out with Islam, sir?
>> Well, they are too far gone and I'll
elaborate, but actually I'd like to talk
a little bit about your earlier point
about Hungary um and or bond. You know
what's interesting and what's beneficial
to us today is that if you recall over
10 years ago around 2014 and 2015,
that's when the American people were
first introduced to Victor Orban um of
Hungary. And why? Because the media was
demonizing him as the next Hitler. Okay,
he was uh I I remember everything I saw
and I wrote about him back then. He was
just described as this horrible human
being, a monster and a creeping
dictator. That's a direct quote. The
Guardian said he needs to be eliminated
and taken out. Okay, so he was the next
literally Hitler and um why? Because he
refused to take in Muslim migrants. He
made the civilizational argument all the
way 10 years ago saying this is about
civilizations. We've lived under Islamic
occupation for 150 years. We don't want
it. and he said if France and Belgium
and whoever wants it they can have it.
Okay. Now what's good about that is if
you fast forward 10 years now we can
actually evaluate what he said and his
position with what has happened and what
has happened is a complete disaster for
all those other countries that did take
in large numbers of Muslim populations
as we can see. Um and as he made a very
good point and speaking of uh you know
right around Christmas he he sent a
tweet basically saying we the Hungarians
are paying a million or something euros
a day as penalty because they don't take
in the Muslim migrants but it's worth it
because look we can actually have a
normal Christmas whereas in the rest of
Europe Christmas markets were were
cancelled there were barriers everywhere
the entire uh you know traditional feel
was gone there were no statues or
crosses because they might offend
certain people who did in fact destroy
nativity scenes and whatnot. So yeah, he
time has proven his position correct.
But to your other question about France
and uh you know the UK, what they have
to understand is they have reached the
point of no return. In other words,
someone like Orban and his policy and
Poland, they they nipped it in the bud.
They said from the beginning, okay, and
it was easy. They said we don't want
Muslim migrants and that was it. There
was no war. There was no conflict.
Nations like these other Western
European nations who've taken in
millions and they have very large Muslim
populations well over 10%. I think they
try to intentionally hide it and make it
sound smaller. They're stuck with it. In
other words, no matter what they do, if
they all become Victor Orban tomorrow,
they still have to always live with a
huge Muslim population in their country.
And that's always going to be a problem.
>> It's where do people go to get you at
the Danube Institute? Where they go to
the website, the books and social media.
[music] brother, you've been an
inspiration to the folks in Texas and
the United States.
>> Thanks very much, Steve. Uh, one place
is just easy. My name, Raymond Ibrahim,
R A Y M O N D I B R A H I N.com.
That's my website. You'll find links to
everything. Social media, X getter, my
books, and also my YouTube channel, but
be sure to check that out, too.
>> Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.